[Music]
ah
just what i needed how about you poo
[Music]
poo maybe you should slow down a bit
there friend
who are you okay are you okay poo poo oh
bother
starting cpr
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that dives headfirst into a
honeypot of theories only to pass out in
a sugar coma with 20 20 keeping me
locked inside with a toddler i've broken
down and broken out
a couple of the classics from my
childhood to show him there's mickey
mouse
there's mulan but his favorite is the
1977 classic
animated movie the many adventures of
winnie the pooh granted he really
only likes to listen to the theme song
30 times in a row and run around in
counterclockwise circles to it but well
he was doing that
over and over and over again i was
theorizing this movie was a
staple of my childhood and it's been
really fun to go back and watch it but
looking at it now through theory-addled
eyes i
have a few questions for old pooh there
there are quite a few winnie the pooh
theories out there in the world and i
mean this stuff goes deep i think one of
the weirdest that's gained a lot of
traction over the years is that the
internet claims the characters from the
100 acre wood represent the seven deadly
sins
rabbit is wrath because he's always
angry owl is pride because he's so cocky
and confident all the time you get the
idea who is of course gluttony
constantly eating honey and hungry for
more but i'm not interested in the seven
deadly sins idea i think that one is a
bit of a stretch even i have my limits
but i
am interested in poo's honey obsession
it's a clear driving force for him
throughout these movies we literally
never see him
eat anything else so i asked myself if
it would be possible for poo
to survive only on honey alone at first
it was just a little thought experiment
honestly but it ended up here as an
episode because there's a lot more than
just a smackerel of biology involved and
also
this is like the only disney theory i've
done that's not about the main character
being evil
or dead or about to die or is it just
kidding this is winnie the pooh we're
talking about you're here because you
like things that are cute
and relaxing and get you to think think
think so today let's think think think
together and get this episode started a
few ground rules to this theory since
yes
i know pooh and his friends are stuffed
animals in reality it means that none of
the plushie characters
actually have to eat to survive but
we're assuming here that pooh is gonna
be a real bear because well that's how
he's depicted in the movies he's a
plushie bear sure but he still roams
around the forest eating honey by the
pot load even in the live-action movie
christopher robin
the stuffed teddy bear is still trying
to consume
very real world honey so we're just
gonna go with that
plus we need poo to eat honey so we can
continue to live on
in the very real imaginary world of our
hearts to start with i think there's a
simpler question that we need to answer
first
do real bears actually eat honey i'm
sure most of you are probably rolling
your eyes at this point of course
bears eat honey matpat but honestly i
was a bit skeptical
bees are serious business and if you're
a bear you're looking for the path of
least resistance between you
and your dinner so my assumption would
be that most bears were only getting
honey from like
unsuspecting campers who also somehow
think that honey is a camping necessity
i thought that the idea might just be
movie nonsense that we've been fed
throughout our childhoods but i actually
did some research and it turns out the
idea of bears eating honey is based on
real world fact
according to national geographic quote
all bears are considered omnivores and
yes
they all love the taste of honey other
sources state that this is because honey
is made up of the simple sugars glucose
and fructose which can be
broken down quickly by mammals for a
quick boost of energy plus
the sweet addicting qualities of sugar
keep them coming back for more
it's basically the bear equivalent of us
with candy you say you're only going
back for a couple of m m's before you
know it the whole bag is gone there's
even closed circuit tv footage of bears
in china sneaking into a local nature
reserve to eat the honey collected in
the apiary
clearly bears very much want to eat
honey but
could they survive on it well we're not
really interested in whether
all bears could survive we only care
about one bear in particular
different species of bear have different
biological requirements so to answer
this question we really need to figure
out what kind of
bear is a pooh bear winnie the pooh was
created by
a.a milne in 1926 and was based on his
son's stuffed bear his son
christopher robin milne named the toy
after a popular american black bear
at london zoo called winnipeg so is that
her answer then he's a black bear well
just because pooh was
named after a black bear it doesn't
guarantee that that's what he is so to
double check let's compare
pooh to other types of bears there are
eight species of bear in existence today
the north american black bear the brown
bear the polar bear the asiatic black
bear
the andean bear the panda bear the sloth
bear and the sun bear we can discount a
few right off the bat
pooh is very clearly not a panda based
on his lack of fur patterns this logic
can also be applied to the andean bear
with pooh lacking the famous
spectacled face markings as well as the
sloth sun and asiatic black bears with
pooh lacking the prominent chest
markings he's also not a polar bear
given the fact that he lives in a forest
rather than the arctic
after that we're left with only two
types of bear the brown bear and the
american black bear but matpat i hear
you say who
is clearly yellow not black or brown to
which i say
not so fast first the original witty the
pooh is not yellow he was in fact brown
in bringing him to film
disney blondified him as they did with
christopher robin who was also a
brunette in real life
also sure who is yellow in the movie but
actually both brown and black bears have
been seen in a variety of colors
including black brown
and even golden blonde there are also a
couple of other historic and geographic
reasons that pooh has to be one of these
two species
first conveniently the 100-acre wood is
based on a real forest the 500-acre wood
in the uk
while not the most interestingly named
the reference is clear
and the bear that used to roam the uk in
these woods was a subspecies
of brown bear however that still doesn't
close the book on this because pooh is
after all
also a teddy bear and they happen to
have a very specific origin story
in 1902 the story goes that president
theodore roosevelt refused to shoot a
black bear that his associates had tied
up to a tree this then became a
political cartoon and inspired morris
mitchum to create the very first
teddy bear named after theodore
roosevelt teddy the president
this funny little piece of presidential
legend political propaganda became the
most ubiquitously owned
toy in the world in the century since so
we have ourselves the two main suspects
but which is it fortunately there are a
few key features that can help us
distinguish each type of bear let's
start with brown bear they tend to have
small
round ears deep sunken eyes close
together and a disc shaped snout where
there's a clear curve between the top of
the head and the tip of the nose brown
bears also have a very defined
shoulder hump which is the highest point
of their body when they're on all fours
black bears on the other hand have
longer more erect ears eyes that sit
further apart and
no shoulder hum and because of that they
have more of a teardrop body shape with
the rump being the highest part so now
let's look at pooh
his ears stand on end and are more oval
than round so one point for black bear
we can definitely see from the face that
his eyes are set further apart
another point as for body shape pooh
clearly doesn't have a shoulder hump and
although we never see him walking on all
fours his torso is larger at the bottom
and gets narrower as it goes up
pointing to the likelihood that his rump
would be higher so it would seem that
pooh
is indeed an american black bear now
that we've established the kind of bear
poo
is we can start to work out what he
needs to survive the average american
blackberry needs to consume 8 000
calories every day during the spring and
a whopping
20 000 calories in the fall to get ready
to hibernate
however we already know that poo doesn't
hibernate due to the many times that we
see him playing out in the snow and
that's not all the average black bear is
five to seven
feet or one and a half to 2.1 meters
tall when stood on their hind legs given
the fact that we see pooh
standing next to a child it's unlikely
that pooh is nearly that tall
to get a better understanding of how
many calories a bear his size would need
to consume we need to figure out his
height
now i thought that this would be simple
but it turns out there's no cannon
height for winnie the pooh a character
that's been around since 1926
does not have himself a cannon height a
quick google search
suggested that pooh is 22 inches or 56
centimeters tall
but the source for this was sketchy at
best it's mainly a random collection of
pages based on winnie the pooh
godzilla and american cereal of all the
things to have a website for i don't
think i'd ever have thought to put
winnie the pooh alongside godzilla and
captain crunch
though god admit i definitely watched
that show long story short i took
matters into my own hands and brought
out the pixel measurements
it would be nearly impossible to measure
poo in the cartoon given none of the
characters have canon heights and the
objects tend to be proportional to them
rather than to the world instead i
turned to the 2018
live-action film christopher robin ewan
mcgregor who plays christopher robin has
a height of 1.77 meters or
5 foot 10 inches therefore we should be
able to take shots of poo
next to him and figure out his height
but after hours of measuring
i got nothing due to angles and
perspective every time i did the math
or maths if you're using the proper
version of english i got a slightly
different answer it would range anywhere
from
20 to 25 inches or 51 to 63.5
centimeters all around the right range
but nothing definitive at this point i
was ready to give up but then i
remembered this shot
why is that shot important well poo is
put in a british red telephone box and
their
sizes are standardized the box that
they're in
is a k-6 model and yes of course i'm up
on my british telephone box types aren't
you this is clear because we can see
that it has eight rows of glass with the
middle panes being much wider than the
two on either side
previous models like k2 3 and 4 had six
rows of equal sized panes and the k1 had
four rows of two equal sized panes plus
modern versions tend to be one solid
pane of glass so it is unquestionably a
k6 telephone box in the movie
based on the standardized size of k6
telephone boxes i can
now say definitively that poo is in fact
22 inches or 56 centimeters which in an
ironic twist means that that sketchy
website was right that is several
hours of my life that i'm not getting
back should have listened to that
godzilla cereal website
if we compare this to the smallest
average black bear five feet or one and
a half meters who is just over
a third of that size so if you break
down the amount of calories per day in
the spring per centimeter of height
who would need a calorie intake of just
over 2980 calories per day
that's not that much but for someone
who's 22 inches high it's pretty
substantial and poo is supposed to only
be eating honey
does honey contain enough calories is
there even enough honey in the hundred
100-acre wood to keep them alive for
those answers i had to look into one of
my new favorite topics sunny science and
yes it is a real thing in fact in 1912
there was an annual journal released and
it's still going strong today entitled
bee
world that would discuss and i quote the
progressive interests of modern bee
culture you like jazz and people think
that being in the movies makes you a
nerd in volume 32 issue two of b-world
eva crane wrote a paper focusing on the
amount of honey a colony of bees can
yield in a year
in this paper she notes that the caloric
value of honey is 1400 calories per
pound or 31 calories per kilogram which
adds up because that's what we see
advertised today
on average a strong colony in a good
year produces 30 to 60 pounds or 14 to
27 kilograms of honey in a 365 day span
equating to about .16 pounds or 70 grams
of honey per day
this would only give poo 224 calories
for his daily meal
far below what he needs to survive but
again that's just
one colony of bees how many colonies of
bees are there likely to be in the
hundred acre wood
well we've only seen a couple of hives
on the show but that's where eva crane
comes in again she states that one
colony of bees
needs one acre of well-pollinated land
in order to produce those averages
in theory the hundred acre wood could
have a hundred colonies living there
each within their own acre
obviously it could be more as bees have
been known to travel up to five miles it
could be less but for the sake of clean
numbers let's just say that there are a
hundred colonies this means then that
even in a low season there would be
around
3 000 pounds or 1 361 kilograms of honey
every year
that is over 4 million calories per year
giving poo a more than healthy 11
500 calories per day to live off of
that's over four times what we estimated
he would need it also means that pooh
would have to travel about 26 acres
every day to get his fill
maybe that's why we see him wandering
around so much so
is that it who just survives well if
you're familiar with this channel you
know i couldn't just leave it there
technically for a blackberry size pooh
could find his requisite
3000 calories per day but that isn't
necessarily a good thing
black bears are opportunistic eaters by
nature because of this
75 to 95 of their diet tends to be
vegetation
things like grass berries nuts if the
environment allows for it they'll also
fill a portion of their diet with
rodents
birds fish insects all of this is an aid
of collecting
fats carbohydrates protein the fats and
carbs get broken down
stored and used for energy but protein
has a bigger role here helping to
balance hormones
creating and repairing muscles as well
as being a source of energy it also has
the added bonus of making you feel
fuller faster whereas things like sugar
and simple carbs often make you feel
hungrier sooner
honey does provide carbs that the body
can use for energy but it doesn't
contain any protein which is why it
isn't usually a major
source of food for bears notice how i
said isn't usually that's because under
normal circumstances bears don't just
eat honey bears will eat everything
inside the beehive the honey the larvae
even the bees themselves
this balances out the sugary carbs with
the much needed protein but with poo
we see him spitting out the bees he only
eats the honey inside
so poo is gonna be getting some energy
out of this but without any protein in
his diet he actually starts to run into
a number of health risks the first of
which is that he's malnourished we've
all seen those videos online of a
starving pet that's been abandoned their
bones showing through their skin
barely able to walk it's a sad sight be
sure and the reason they look like this
is because they're malnourished protein
unlike fatter carbohydrates can't be
stored for the body to draw in later so
if you're not eating enough protein the
body does the only thing it can do and
finds what it needs within the body
who's hunger is never satisfied because
his body is crying out for the nutrients
that he's not getting and that's not the
only problem that he faces
as poo's body begins to eat away at his
internal proteins
it very well may start to eat away at
the protein p10
this protein is what scientists believe
allow bears to gain so much weight
before hibernation but also never
contract
diseases like type 2 diabetes how pten
works is it tells the body to store
sugar
rather than immediately breaking it down
and sending it through the body this
means they have a large supply of sugar
built up
so when they hibernate it can slowly be
released to give the body energy and
keep their blood sugar levels regulated
if poo's body isn't getting any protein
and begins to eat away
at p10 he isn't gonna store the sugar to
release it safely when he needs it
instead he'll have dangerous levels of
sugar pulsing through his body which his
body won't be able to handle
and winnie the pool reach the same
inevitable consequence that all of us do
type 2 diabetes that's right if poo
doesn't start diversifying his diet and
picking up a few of those carrots from
rabbit's garden he's heading down a
dangerous path towards honey induced
diabetes pretty soon he'll start feeling
fatigued
feeling abnormally thirsty get blurred
vision itchy skin
sudden weight loss and wouldn't you know
it always feeling hungry
it's a little concerning that poo is
always constantly asking for another
small smack roll of something and that's
probably not just regular hunger he's
feeling but his body telling him it
needs a much better balanced diet if
he's going to keep hunting hephalons in
the hundred acre wood
all that's to say maybe it's for the
best that our childhood imagination
doesn't manifest itself in real life all
that often
since pooh turns out to be not only a
bear of very little brain but also a
bear
of very likely diabetes and rabbit is
pretty spot on to hide his honey jars
whenever poo comes a knock in so is
poo's love of honey plausible yeah
totally is it possible for him to get
enough interestingly enough absolutely
is it now christopher robin's
responsibility to make sure pooh doesn't
eat himself into a diabetic coma in the
middle of the hundred acre
wood most definitely sorry christopher
welcome to adulting
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts winnie the pooh captain
crunch and godzilla
looking for flavors through time and
space
honey and kaiju mixed in with their
cereal what other adventures could they
stuff in their face
you